I'm just gonna drink and celebration hi
my name is Mary and I've been a drama
teacher for about 13 years now my name
is Eric I've been teaching improv in
theatre for like ten years
I'm Tommy and I've been teaching drama
for over 15 years I'm Jonah and I've
been teaching drama for four years there
are some classics and some Shakespeare
that I know rather well
[Music]
okay bring it on bring it on let's do it
are you ready what's next act 5 scene 2
okay ending though is Hamlet dies okay
the main things definitely all happens
and people that died or Claudius dies
Gertrude dies Hamlet dies can I be
Gertrude do you want to be the king sure
I'll be the king okay I'm bad boy Hamlet
the swords I gave them were poison go
ham-a-cow or Who am I ready for oh wait
yeah of course there's my son
Hamlet go kill weirdies I bet they're
gonna die cuz that sword was so poised
Hamlet well done I'm gonna cheers with
this cup that my husband's been holding
for you
you die die
poisoned please so nice no everyone's
dead and I'm crazy so now I'm gonna die
[Applause]
Hamlet and Lehren T stools Flaherty's
sword was laced with poison
Claudius will say that he will drink to
Hamlet's Hulk if he's able to hit Lera
tease him it declines the drink the
Queen drinks the cup instead so Laertes
was able to hit Hamlet with the last
sword
Hamlet managed to switch swords with
lair cheese but hit him as well
the Queen was poisoned and dies
responsible for the rest of the poison
[Music]
[Music]
hey tibalt yo I'm Goku show you're gonna
kill me with that sword
I'm gonna defend myself but not very
well you killed Mercutio yes I did Romeo
what are you gonna do about it
no you're not yes I am you all married
Julia Julia Julia everyone's angry at
Romeo and I think what you need to do is
just go to apothecary and get some fake
potion and pretend your debts that we
can get you out of here you can marry
him somewhere else
go I'm your nurse by temporary
[Applause]
Mercurio decides to fight Tibble Nicky
show is killed by Tibble Romeo fight
still kills him by the ballet his
parents know know that she's getting
married to Paris Romeo the plan
Juliet dies I've never got to Romeo
Romeo soon as Julia is dead
purchases poison ghosts Juliet's tomb
thanks that poison Juliet wakes to see
Romeo dead she stabs herself with a
dagger Scottish play haggis it up scenes
one there are 11 scenes a night five a
trance mm-hmm the last part of it is
Macduff kills Macbeth and announces
mouth of the new Kings everyone has to
talk okay malcolm and macduff who's
Malcolm you're you're a witch no please
medium and can also be the witch after
that you need the crown
Oh medium how are you I'm worried about
you I hope you don't kill yourself oh no
I think she just killed herself
alright well at least I am safely the
king and I am going to rest easy being
king knowing that those witches told me
that no man of woman born will ever harm
Macbeth until Burnham would come to
Dunsinane that's right oh no those are
men dressed as trees walking towards me
is that what the witches were talking
about when they mentioned dancing on the
Birnam wood what's your name
make Macduff are you Duncan son Malcolm
I bet you aren't a fan of me cuz I
killed your dad no I frickin hate right
no you don't kill me cuz no one of woman
born I knew you you were definitely of
woman born right you worried that you
were not timely you weren't untimely a
little spots gone yet get out of here
you weren't untimely ripped from your
mother's womb perchance were you uh I
slipped right out at the right time
don't know see you say yes you weren't
untimely whipped from your mother's womb
not through the vagina were you the time
was not timely and fast say yes were you
ripped out yeah oh no you were not a
woman born which means it's possible
that you'll kill me cut off my head oh
no he cut off my head you're holding my
hand okay hey wassup yo killed this guy
he loves blood man I think I'm king no
I'm
[Applause]
castle he's not scared because only a
man no woman born could ever kill him
Lady Macbeth dies the death goes into
battle Macduff challenges Macbeth
Macbeth says he cannot be killed
Macduff tells him that he was not born
Robert ripped from his mother picked up
kills Macbeth he had to have a plus
because it's so fun to just play a bunch
of characters in a sort of frantic
manner I enjoyed him I thought I thought
it was difficult just because I haven't
brushed up on a lot of these in years I
know people are gonna be like oh they
should know their drama teachers you
reenact half a Hamlet it's not that easy
it can be daunting it can be scary like
to read a Shakespeare and understand it
so it's like a fun exercise okay the
costumes weren't alive I feel like I
made my English teachers and my theatre
teachers
[Music]
you